démenti jeudi belles vous parlez
beaucoup hein mais vous avez un bon
délire
alors on va faire un truc c'est son
affaire
l'interview sans la bouche on a beau
cheval dans les guignols
alors dans un dîner un producteur très
connus vous proposant rôle très
important en vous appelant françoise
toujours dans ce dîner arrive votre pire
ennemi moufter pas la bouffe est infect
dans ce dîner à chier alors bon la
bouffe est infect vous picoler
effectivement un moment vous allez aux
toilettes
vous vous trompez de portes et vous
tombez sur un couple deux mecs en train
de baiser d'accord à la fin du dîner
tout le monde offre un cadeau aux
maîtres de maison parce qu'en fait ce
dîner était organisé pour son
anniversaire et vous avez rien à lui
offrir avant le suffit
tesla fait là alors vous rentrez chez
vous en voiture les flics vous arrête
ils vous reconnaissez pas à la lie le
reconnaît
en arrivant chez vous il ya une lettre
du laboratoire mettant simplement tine
ouais d'accord
votre fils vous appelle il pourra pas
vous rejoindre cette nuit et ça fait
deux fois cette semaine à vous 1
à votre âge